[Music]
it's very different from every other
collection in the world and if you're a
collector at heart you can't really stop
my name is chef mm I'm the curator and
owner of the Icelandic phallological
Museum
my father was given a dried bull penis
epistle back in 1974 as a joke then
that's Ramos Park the idea you know to
start collecting these things all the
lights are made from scrotum skins
right now we have 285 different
specimens it's still growing the
collection we get maybe three to five
every year the most fascinating things
is the diversity there are huge
differences in size shapes a color etc
here is the the biggest specimens we
have it's a sperm whale it's about 70
kilos maybe 150 pounds and here is one
of my favorites the world was one the
hardest to get was the human one no
question about that it was 95 when he
died so the specimen is a bit shrunken
you know it's what age does to people
you know everything shrinks but we're
hopeful we'll get a better example show
people say you know they are just happy
because they realize that less nothing
loot here there's no pornography it's
just you know educational fun
[Music]